HERE DONATO
ONE-TIMER
SKINNER.
A GOOD NET DRIVE BY DONSKOI TO
FIRST OPPORTUNITYN O NET TO GO
IN, ALSO THE CONFIDENCE WILL
HELP YOUALL-TIME
SHOT-BLOCK LEADER,
THEY SCORE.
LEON DRAISAITL.
AS THEY MAKE IT LOOKST, JUST KI
LOST, OUT OF THE
WIDE.
FOEGELE LOOKING FOR THE TIP.
NOW DEEP OUT OF THE CORNER. TWO.
DRAISAITL LEADS THE WAY.
CHRIS KROTING LARSSON, ADAM
LARSSON RIGHT IN, HE SCOOORES!
POST, ABLE TO CATCH THAT PUCK,
MOVE IT UP TO ADAM LARSSON.
SENDS IT IN FOR RYAN DONATO.
A
CUT ACROSS.ARVI SEALS THE WALL
DETROIT ON WEDNESDAY.
GOURDE.
NEW EQUIPMENT.
AND IT WENT
IN,
MIGHT HAVE TIPPED OFF THE GLOVE.
LOOKED L IN, HE SCOOORES!
WHAT A GOAL! RACES, NICE MOVE H
THEY SCOOOORE!
THAT'S HOCK CREDIT FOR
THIS GOAL ATTEMPTING TO PASS TO
HE'LL STICK
GUARDED BY MARCUS JOHANSSON.
NUGENT-HOPKINS.
THINKS ABOUT A  MIDDLE.
FOR McDAVID.
TRIES TO POWER OUT ,
NIEMELAINEN.T
IT'S A BROKEN STICK FOR GEEKIE E
IN FRONT.
SKINNER HAS TO GSHOT, TIPPED,
THEY
THE TIP OUT WIDE IS McDAVID. TA
WIDE, PULJUJARVI OUT FRONT,
McDAVID, ONE-TIMER, BARRIE, SPOT
ON